ja das was heute am ende passiert ist
das ist ein wirklich seltenes ereignis
und genau genommen ist es nicht nur ein
ereignis
es sind gleich drei außergewöhnliche
ereignisse zusammen gekommen eine flut
von stream5 ein sichtbarer super mond
und zeitgleich auch ein blauer mund
dieses spektakel nennt sich dann super
blaublut mondfinsternis und das hat es
zuletzt vor 150 jahren gegeben was wir
der geburt eines schlumpfs zu tun hat
von wo aus dieses himmelsspektakel von
der erde aus zu sehen war und warum uns
dieses phänomen für zukünftige
mondmissionen hilfreich sein kann jetzt
den krieg zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen da übrigens auch wieder einen
themenvorschlag von whatsapp ganz viele
haben da gesagt macht dieses thema und
hier ist es wenn ihr auch bei whatsapp
dabei sein sollte der link ist dann am
ende des videos und unten in dem video
beschreibung ja vielleicht habe das
mitbekommen im januar gab es gleich zwei
mal einen vollmond dieses phänomen wird
auch blaue und genannt und ist schon
ziemlich außergewöhnlich wohl deswegen
gibt es eine englische sprache auf das
sprichwort once im blumenmeer damals die
fernsehserien die schlümpfe gesehen hat
weiß jetzt auch dass ein schlumpf
vielleicht jetzt auf die welt kommt und
ja der mond steht der erde gerade
besonders nahe
er erscheint viel größer am himmel und
so kamen zum vollmond auch noch das
phänomen des super mondes dazu das ist
gerade am frühen nachmittag europäischer
zeit passiert genau wie übrigens bereits
am dritten dezember und auch schon
anfang januar der mond also ist also der
erde ungewöhnlich nah gekommen 364.000
kilometer haben uns getrennt nur damit
das besser euch vorstellen können die
mittlere entfernung liegt bei 384 1000
km
langfristig wird solch einem zweier day
zwischen mond und erde immer seltener
vorkommen denn die bahn des mondes
entfernt sich jedes jahr um etwa 3,8
zentimeter von der erde
jedenfalls steht fest dass die
gemessenen helligkeit des mondes bei
solch einem super mond um etwa 30
prozent größer ist als bei der
durchschnittlichen entfernung als würde
das nicht reichen hat sich zudem super
und blauen vollmond auch noch etwas rot
dazu gemischt denn in der selben nacht
gab es jetzt also ich jetzt also bei uns
am tag gab es laut us raumfahrtbehörde
nasa auch eben eine totale
mondfinsternis der mond scheint
michael roth und wird in diesem zustand
als blutmond bezeichnen der grund die
erde schiebt sich zwischen mond und
sonne und wirft ihren schatten auf dem
mond später verdeckt ziehen ganz die
erde schont also die sonnenstrahlen ab
doch einige werden von der erdatmosphäre
gebrochen und zum mond geworfen
dies sind langweilige infrarotstrahlen
die den mond in die geheimnisvolle
gestalt des blut mondes hüllen
genauso übrigens wie beim sonnenauf- und
-untergang dann wird das licht der sonne
ja auch rot etwas korrekter als die
bezeichnung mondfinsternis wäre also so
etwas wie mond rettung der begriff
blutmond deutet es ja schon an für die
nasa war das ereignis übrigens jetzt
ganz besonders spannend denn diese
mondfinsternis bietet die möglichkeit zu
erforschen was passiert wenn die
mondoberfläche sehr schnell abkühlt
dadurch wollen die nasa
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
neue erkenntnisse zum sogenannten
regolith also dem locker material
gewinnen das ist grob gesagt das gemisch
von lockerem gestein und boden auf der
mondoberfläche dazu einer der
beteiligten wissenschaftler noah pedro
von der nasa während einer
mondfinsternis ist der wechsel der
temperatur so krass dass es so aussieht
als würde die mondoberfläche von einem
ofen zu einem gefrierschrank übergehen
und das innerhalb weniger stunden das
war sein team hat das himmelsphänomen
vom haller karla observatorium auf der
insel maui hawaii beobachtet zitat der
ganze charakter des mondes verändert
sich wenn wir ihnen während einer
finsternis mit einer wärmebildkamera
beobachten im dunkeln können viele
vertraute krater und andere merkmale
nicht gesehen werden und die
normalerweise unscheinbaren bereiche um
einige kracher beginnen zu blühen weil
die felsen dort noch warm sind ja das
sagt der weltraum physiker paul hey in
welchem tempo die oberfläche wärme
verliert hängt von der größe des
gesteins und auch der
materialeigenschaft ab je nachdem die
porös ist beispielsweise ist diese
informationen über die geologische
beschaffenheit des mondes die können
jetzt zb genutzt werden um geeignete
landeplätze für zukünftige mondmissionen
zu identifizieren wir in europa konnten
das ereignis nur indirekt über das
internet beobachten die drei
himmelsereignis waren lediglich in
neuseeland australien ostasien
im westen von nordamerika perfekt zu
beobachten und zwar mit bloßem auge im
gegensatz zur sonnenfinsternis ist das
nämlich dann möglich übrigens die
nächste mondfinsternis wird es
berechnungen zufolge wohnt am 27 juli
dieses jahres geben
ein kleines geburtstagsgeschenk für mich
und die wird dann auch aus europa zu
sehen sein wenn das wetter mitspielt im
sommer wird der mond allerdings sehr
klein sein und auch der termin für den
nächsten super blaublut und der steht
schon fest astronomie teams haben ihn
auf den 31 januar 2037 datierten mal
sehen ob wir dann auch hier in europa
live sehen können wenn ihr die berichten
dann 2037 pixum als erste sehen wollt
dann meldet euch hier bei whatsapp an
dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der glocke vergessen und hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
helium-3 abbau auf dem mond china als
erster ansonsten bis dann flattern